occupied by Israel because this trip is
a small area of land on the east coast
of the Mediterranean
and it's one of the most crowded places
in the world more than 2 million people
live in an area of 365 square kilometers
and that's more than 5 000 people per
square kilometer in urban areas there is
up to 20 000.
16 years of blockade by Israel has led
to a crisis of overpopulation in the
Gaza Strip
now food shortages are expected to
increase in the coming years
like 60 percent of people in Gaza
Mohamed Salama has been living in a
shorted refugee camp since it was
established by the un's Palestinian
refugee agency unra more than 70 years
ago
he said it was much empty at the time
now he says it's crammed with
multi-story buildings and narrow alleys
this area used to be Greenland but as a
number of people doubled anura bought it
and Built Homes to give to refugees the
number of homes has continued to
increase and people are also adding more
stories to existing buildings
according to officials in Gaza its
population is increasing by about 60
000 or 3 percent a year
a large part of the area in Gaza cannot
be built or expanded upon because it's
next to the borders of Israeli
occupation so the effective area of the
Gaza Strip is less than the actual area
although accurate
agriclear the overpopulation crisis is
putting pressure on resources is
especially food production and
distribution
that's made worse by the blockade and
Israeli forces attacking and bombarding
farming land
repeated Israeli attacks The Continuous
bulldozing of lands and the Israeli
Siege all of this has decreased the
agricultural area and it will take many
years to rehabilitate these lands
according to the world food program more
than 70 percent of godson's Food
Supplies are insecure
despite efforts of eight organizations
and local farmers life is getting
tougher for the increasing number of
people facing hardship and hunger
without
urgent intervention the situation is
likely to worsen with devastating
consequences facing the people of Gaza
in the coming years